last evening with the library on
exploratory analysis thank you okay this
is a project that I've been working
lately for out of my ultimate automating
the exploratory analysis of databases so
the problem is very simple when you
start a new project and you data project
your customer or internal customers send
you that either set data set or a
database so what do you do
basically you you think about it you
compute some frequencies calculate
semester these six try to see some
trends in data trying to know the data
that you will work in with but then it
sends it your customer sends you ten new
tables to analyze what do you do it you
try to repeat the same process again you
you try to don't leave any data out you
want to know the data so two weeks later
the new the new databases complete
databases with n modern or approach 200
tables each then the process the process
is kind of it's linear so if you spend
two hours revising one table you
multiply the first two hours for X
tables so the the library will show you
basically try to alleviate this process
it's called Auto ever before automated
exploratory data analysis it works for
databases and basically you have two
connections source database that you
want to analyze you have as many as you
want you just pile up this databases and
one metadata database where you will put
all the metadata from these these tables
for from this databases so how it works
basically the library or the descript
how to generate SQL code
and it's tracked column names table
names features like missing values nulls
in the data set
temporal grouping of the data when you
have time time stamps and some
statistics you just need to provide a
connection to them to your source and a
connection to your metadata database
this is a simple configuration basically
you import the library and you basically
pass the two connections or you import
the two connections and you just need to
configure it here where is the server
you specify what type of engine a MySQL
SQL server is working pretty well
Postgres as well and SQLite and
basically just these connections are
where the server leaves the root the
password I'm using for this example the
employees database from MySQL so in line
15 basically it calls the library using
these connections you just pass these
connections you have your doing your
databases and we will see we example of
this so basically I'm calling this
Explorer
I called Meetup it makes the connection
read first the columns of the tables
then reads the tables and it start
extracting information from the columns
distinct values news and then the the
temporal data it grouped the temporal
data automatically so at the end of the
process you just limit this running at
the end of the process you will have a
database that you can query and put any
tool that you want to visualize so the
back end or the metadata database will
have six tables at the moment but four
tables columns you can see the
in the repository I will show that at
the end of the presentation and
basically it it goes through all the
kind of metadata you would like to
analyze and you have everything in one
place
what are the good things about this is
that that it's not just for one database
you could pull data from different
engines for example so compare data or
having one repository databases for from
my secure well from a secure server in
the same repository and compare it
analyze it see if you have data from one
that lives in the other you could do a
lot of analysis romance one single
repository so this is a just a
visualization blur I pick slice a little
bit but you can you could put build this
on your own just waiting the tables the
server names the table names for this
example I have like five billion rows
analyzed for three thousand columns
analyzed and 823 tables and you just
build up so the things you extract the
metadata it's very lightweight so even
analyzing five billion rows of data
it's basically 30 megabytes 50 megabytes
which is very handle for database and
you can basically have access off to the
information that you need you can
analyze the time series data all the all
the time series is basically automated
automatically stored in a different
database monthly you can change that to
weekly or yearly if you want and
basically query that data when you need
especially if you have a new requirement
you could search by data value for
example or names of the columns when you
that's the thank you
[Applause]